but first we're winning that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
now in the GOP Primary season the two
biggest dogs in the pen they're already
getting into it
when the Rhonda sanctimonious facts come
out you will see that
he's better than most Democrat Governors
but very average at best compared to
Republican Governors who have done a
fantastic job look at Disney and what a
mess it is
could have worked out an easy settlement
but know he wanted to show the fake news
how tough a guy he is he's not he did
great for three years but when he turned
the country over to fauci in March of
2020 that destroyed millions of people's
lives and in Florida we were one of the
few that stood up cut Against the Grain
took incoming fire from media
bureaucracy the left even a lot of
Republicans
well this is going to be fascinating to
watch we all know that and we'll watch
the drama through the debates and while
at times egos will be bruised and
tempers will flare
let's not lose perspective or Focus
because as Rough and Tumble as things
are going to get we should never forget
that on key issues we're winning
on the debt ceiling speaker McCarthy has
the White House backed into a corner I
love this although Democrats rarely
break ranks there are signs now that
Biden's Coalition is cracking so as the
deadline nears for a deal well it's hard
to see how Democrats with their slim
Senate majority don't end up demanding
that Biden cut a deal because their
majority is on the line next election
now the public wants spending cuts as
part of the debt ceiling hike we've seen
those polls and the house can say look
we already passed a bill to do both
raise the debt ceiling and give you some
spending cuts
and all the while McCarthy did The
Impossible he kept his fractious
Coalition together
we knew this will not would not be easy
it's hard but we're working and we're
going to continue to work till we get
this done we want to make sure this is
an agreement worthy of the American
people and so it takes a while to make
it happen and we're working hard to make
it happen now it's going so poorly for
the White House that even far left hate
site Salon they're panicking saying from
top to bottom this Administration cannot
frame an argument does not engage the
press and for reasons unknown doesn't
even appear to want to do either
or maybe just maybe guys the basement
campaign that Biden ran in 2020 should
have kind of tipped you off
but of course as we said all along here
on the angle the problem for Biden is
one of substance and judgment it's not a
messaging problem really
and meanwhile Republicans they finally
convinced the public that the problem
here with inflation and all these other
you know tangential uh problems that
come off of that is Runaway spending and
it's obvious that Biden totally
misjudged what kind of shape the economy
would be in at this point in the
negotiations
it's in terrible shape so he has no
leverage but McCarthy he has plenty
and while the elites were writing the
obituary and I remember this well for
America First Republicans just a few
years ago today the wisdom of their
position is becoming more apparent by
the day
even Politico recognizes that Biden's
new economic World Order that's falling
apart
the goal is to replace the old paradigms
of globalization free trade and Reliance
on the markets with a worker-centered
trade policy but Biden's Brain Trust has
yet to settle on a vision for how the
next era of global economics will be
constructed their initial ideas are
abstract at best
well abstract ideas is like kind of a
nice way of saying failing agenda
and as far as Biden's Brain Trust is
concerned that's hilarious even the
phrase
they do have a clear agenda
flood the country with non-americans
break public trust in every institution
so racial Discord and dismantle the
middle class
all of that by the way toward the goal
of empowering the elites here in the
elites abroad and along the way remaking
the country we love so much
meanwhile populist conservatives they're
moving on the debate on
re-industrializing the United States to
keep us strong and independent we saw
what happened after covet proposals to
claw Back Essential manufacturing are
becoming more popular now DeSantis did
discuss this last night I want to hear
more about that it's about time
now in the same vein Republicans are
winning the debate on China and who
started that really in a political sense
it was Donald Trump even after China
sent a surveillance balloon over the
United States Biden is still begging for
really you know robust re-engagement
with China as if he's almost bought and
paid for hmm
but the House GOP cited the ongoing
genocide against the uyghurs it's
pushing for more sanctions on Chinese
tech companies and curbs in U.S
investment over there that's good stuff
so now who cares more about human rights
again
[Music]
well we do and not just in China but
here in our own country where Biden's
open borders are enriching the cartels
and leading to human trafficking child
sex sex trafficking and intolerable
conditions at the border the border is
now by the way one of the top three
issues of concern in public opinion
surveys
so both Trump and DeSantis are going to
be telling Americans that it's not just
Central Americans flooding the country
we're now seeing a record number of
Chinese border crossers as well now
check this reporting out from the Daily
Caller news Foundation border patrol
encountered
3182 migrants from China at the U.S
Mexico border in April alone
Chinese migrants have been found with
large sums of U.S currency according to
border patrol agents in total border
patrol has encountered
9711 Chinese migrants at the southern
border between October 2022 and April
marking an already roughly
393 increase compared to all of fiscal
year 2022. this is disturbing to say the
least
and by the way on this issue it's so bad
for the cities that even liberal Mayors
are demanding help from the feds it's a
classic kind of NIMBY moment not in my
backyard for liberals who are finally
finally getting a taste of their own
medicine when it comes to immigration
and of course we all know who's winning
on the cultural issues
the left started this war against
traditionalism and now they're shocked
shocked that Americans and new
immigrants are fighting back
finally this was great to see in
Michigan Muslim Americans are joining
the fight against the sexualized
curricula in our schools went to school
board meetings and they're speaking out
and they tell me that Bud Light is
literally being given away in some
convenience stores after the Dylan
Mulvaney trans Fiasco that backfired big
time
and how about the wins in
republican-controlled state legislatures
they're rolling in obviously in Florida
with DeSantis on the move there but in
Montana in Texas and even places like
purple North Carolina
the Democrat Governor there is freaking
out because of a 12-week abortion ban
well too bad Governor thems the brakes
and now on top of all of this you think
about this in a historical context
the party of FDR and JFK has now become
the party of gender mutilation for
children
but this is backfiring on the Democrats
hugely look at these headlines
I mean one after the other transgender
surgery a ban advances in North Carolina
bans on transition care for young people
spread across the United States
etc etc we didn't have enough time on
the show to put all the headlines up so
we're eating their lunch on all of these
issues
but the left what do they have to offer
racially divisive rhetoric and declining
living standards
and meanwhile our presidential primary
it's going to get tough we know that
but given everything I told you tonight
win after win after win we need to
remain focused on the issues that are
important to the public
immigration and the economy one and two
and also the broad areas of agreement
that all the Republican candidates share
but especially DeSantis and Trump
and do not miss as things get
exceedingly tough the words and
sometimes the actions during this
primary
the good news we're winning and we're
just getting started and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else